[Music]
well we are here today to explain how
you can reach billion of devices using
the Google system and of course
connected through the Google cloud
platform right so before we can start on
some like deep dive on how we can extend
your service your output application for
the assistant you like to give you a
rough introduction about the Google
systems right the actions on Google so
don't think he's gonna have a use Google
system which I'm assuming everyone has
hopefully there might be one person
Google system is all about the
conversation that users could have with
Google you could say something like hey
G get this done hey G remind me this I'm
using the terms in eg because I don't
want to actually activate my phone or
your phone so it's a way that users can
talk to Google and be more productive in
their day in a way that we do that is by
having over a billion devices exactly
for example during many days
you surely interact with different
devices right when you wake up you
already take your phone from your George
or nightstand and then when you're
driving you are you want to hear
something during this day or even if
you're running or you can use one of the
headphones for example with the Google
system so across the day you are using
different devices and I'm pretty sure
that - you want to reach the users
around this day right on this journey so
we can offer your content not only on
your website on your smartphone so we
can extend for across sense across
surfaces right totally and it's not just
suffice it that's also different
languages so Google systems available
multiple different languages that way
we're meeting the users where they're at
in the language that's most comfortable
for them as well so we spent a lot of
time building out these different
locales and languages so that we could
provide the best service for users yeah
for example Kim notice I'm not an
English native speaker and of course if
I had the choice to talk if Brazilian
Portuguese with my assistant will be
great because
sometimes I I don't need to keep
Translate on my mind simple things like
turning the lights on good sound simply
but imagine you're ready okay I talk
English for the food day one she's chill
out at my house and I don't like to keep
talking English sometimes or even I have
children they have five and seven years
they're learning English yet so they
prefer to interact in Portuguese so I'd
imagine you can reach for example we are
talking about the probably the most
populous country in the world
Raziel India so UK it's Spanish so you
have a lot of options of language so
Spanish you can talk with all the Latin
American countries so it's a way you can
make your action available for food
across many countries which is cool to
be like yeah Google system does that but
what does I mean for us as developers
like what do I do with this and this is
where I get really excited because we
can use that all those billion devices
in these different languages to really
expose our content to other users as
well and so I like to start off with
just some terminology yeah because we
use the same logo for Google system
which is a conversation between Google
and users and then there are the actual
devices that's the hardware that exists
and actions now Google is the platform
that allows developers to extend the
Google experience
yeah I like to explain this feature
exactly
for example I have a Android development
around and full stack development
background so at the beginning it took
me at under to understand where the
components are fitting together so for
example here the Google system can
imagine this as your the web or the
Android platform where all the action
the apps or your web apps lives where
they call actions on Google's oh sorry
the devices that have it's working like
your phone and the apps are the actions
so it's just a new name for apps if I
keep sort of saying I develop an app an
application for iGoogle systems with
developing actions because we believe
that you're not developing only the
experience of running an app but much
more you are interacting as an action
you are running
using the Google system so I like to
establish this cooperate comparison if
you want to keep in mind like Google
Seasons your platform actuals of
Google's your apps and devices are your
smartphones or your browser it depends
on where you're compared to definitely
so actually Google is just the platform
in which developers can build
applications or actions that we call it
within our world to expose that content
and to have that functionality so how
does it all work so we're gonna start
off on the right hand side imagine that
both speaking this he's saying something
like okay G talk to a personal chef it's
a made-up action that we made and so
what happens there is a device here's
the keyword grabs the audio and sends
out audio over to Google assistant
Google system will translate that audio
to text we're gonna use our own natural
English processing we're using users
preference we do our own machine
learning ranking as well as the user
profile to figure out what does Nevel
actually want when he says that and
because he explicitly said the name of
an action that exists what's gonna
happen is Google systems gonna ping my
actions back-end and go hey someone
wants to talk to your action exactly and
this is the cool point because for
example in this first part you can see
for the beginning you can handle all the
communication with your service so if
you have for example premium service
premium entitlements or you would like
to check the person is logged or not you
can start right away from the first
interaction so because the Google system
in this case it's working more as a as a
bridge between the user and your
applications like you are take your
phone open the launcher and selecting
one app is what you are doing here you
are saying to assess that act the this
action in this case
yeah definitely cuz after that if you
noticed Google system doesn't do much
after it makes the connection after it
that it's all on us so we create the
response you want to give and we give
that response in a text form um in a
JSON format and we send it over to
Google that's it Google system will then
we'll translate that text to speech and
then send that audio over to the device
and actually respond back to
never yes exactly and the cool stuff you
might think be thinking like okay so on
my backhand I have to do force up a
bunch of natural language processing
stuff we understand what the user said
and then identify what it or the user
wants not so not many work right oh my
gosh yeah users are unique and different
I know for myself if you were asked by
partner he would definitely contest that
I'm not the most articulate person
especially when it's something of things
I want in my needs and let me put in my
password so that a processing users yes
for example in this case what we are
saying that you don't need to implement
your own natural language processing to
handle different accents different
languages we have a tool for you to do
that
it's dialogue flow please raise the hand
who already
who knows what dialogue flow is okay
okay so basically it's like intent
matching an entity extraction so
dialogue flow is doing all the work for
you in terms of data fine words the user
said the intent support or what the user
wants you to do and then we you match
exactly to the part on your code and
this is cool because for example you
don't need to have different backends
for different languages we're gonna go
through these on other demos you can
have your own list one single back hand
that you handle all the requests because
everything will be handled in terms of
language and processing but dialogue
flow yes so where does that live within
our kind of flow of data yeah so that
was actually between a Google sisty and
your back-end and so it lives actually
right here and what died a lot flows
gonna do it's going to get that raw tax
to the users utterance and it's gonna
use its own natural language processing
to figure out what do they mean when
they say a statement and then try to
match it with predefined functionalities
as a developer we have defined and if it
doesn't match with anything we have a
default fall back into it which I like
to think as the else statement of all my
intents and it will be captured through
there and so dialogue float just sits
right
between and then it hits our code going
hey there's Janine this part of your
function this function and here are any
of the parameters that you have asked me
to send to you as well and then at that
point we just make our queries for our
database do our Jazz create the response
and then send that back to dialogue the
dialogue flow to Google that's it Google
sent translate that text to speech and
then that audio gets sent to the device
and these in class then milliseconds so
you don't have to worry about overhead
timing and because why do you ask
something you have kind of eight seconds
you have to reply last so if you don't
reply eight seconds the connection be
closed as timeout because of course we
don't want to have actions listen to you
all the time so it will be closed in
eight seconds and you say we might be
thinking okay you have a system dialogue
flow my backhand reading data returning
this all the way around yeah we'll take
class then so few milliseconds so you
can rely you can focus on your own code
cool so we wanted to talk about seeing
that there's so many people who have
used dialogue flow really want to talk
about localizing it because it's one
thing to build an action especially in
your own native language you Billiton
you're like this as awesome as all the
functionality it's you and I want and
now the next thing is how do I expose
this just so many other people because
it's on the building devices but if
somebody is at their own home and
they're only speaking one language you
won't have access to them so what we did
for this particular action it is 4 GDG
which I believe they were talking about
that in the talk Prior about Google
developer groups and so this is a
project that I've been building out
where a Google developer group organizer
can just connect to their meetup API and
it has a fully function action that will
provide information like when's the next
meetup one's last meetup who is an
organizer how many people are there and
it's super easy for our GDG is to set up
and so the first thing that I did to
make it localized was let's see next but
of course this is the way that we have
our I'm using nodejs because remember
client library
in our language in JavaScript and so I
index hot js5 and I had all my coded all
my responses there and so the first
thing I need you in order to localize my
action was I need to actually pull out
all the responses and so I just separate
it have all my response is another
another file and I pulled it in whenever
I wanted this really helped me think
about the responses of my action in big
categories because I had to find this is
the greeting wait this is the greeting
for new users versus the greeting of
returning users which is naturally gonna
be different because when they first
meet my met though I had to go hey
methyl I'm Jessica you know I'm from
Calexico this is kind of my background I
gave him a lingerie scene the first time
I meet him but the tenth time I meet him
I just go hey methyl and that's it and
so your actions want to have that
flexibility too and so by by pulling out
your responses you have to kind of think
about what you want to label the
responses after that because you're
gonna have that pulled out you're gonna
I'm one how about even further separated
where you have a look locales directory
and in there you have your files for
every single language using the same
skeleton of your JSON of your primary
language which this one was in English
and so that way when you're using the
client library you can figure out which
language it's working with so that's the
second step I did after that um I I use
IE TN pull that in as well as moment and
when I had to do was just do some
configuration going hey this is where my
look how my look house are gonna be and
these are the fall backs of a different
location or the different languages that
I might not have predefined so one of
them is for Spanish and so we have
Spanish which is es 419 and then we also
have Spanish which is es - es so 419
means it's Latin America es - es means
that it's in Spain which is very
different Spanish --is I'm treating them
the same so I'm just saying go to my
same Spanish file and use that but you
can have further granularity within that
as well so that's the next thing I did
and then within my code I just hide you
a little bit of refactoring and so this
is my welcome
yes my welcome intact and so what's
happening
is that when my user activates the
action it will greet them and so first
thing it happens is I will localize the
conversation I would figure out where is
the user from what is their locale like
the language are using which I get from
the conversational object that gets
passed back and forth between the user
and me as a developer so I localize it
and then I do some funny jazz about
suggestion chips don't worry about that
and then I have an if statement asking
if I've seen that user before and if I
have seen them I'm gonna give them a
message of the welcome back text and so
you can see I'm using I 18 and doc
double underscore passing in that string
of the name of the e response and then
it creates that message remark for me in
their appropriate language and then it
will send it using the comp da ask well
you can see that me go on the bus you
can see that then we do you can we see
this no yep
thumbs up you could see oh thank you and
then you do here komtar ass sending in
that speech message and then the message
in text form I have two variations I
have a message that's in the audio and
message that is in just text format
because my audio text actually has
natural line breaks that I've put in to
make it sound more natural
and I've actually messed with the
grammar and so instead of asking
questions with a question mark I'm
asking questions with a period because
it changes how the audio is heard as
well
and so I did that for every language
tricking the grammar slightly I didn't
ask for a lot of help from coworkers I
asked a lot from that daughter
translated into Portuguese so thank you
so much yeah and imagine for example
sometimes you on this peach side imagine
you have a conversation we are not your
ability voice comments it's their
difference voice comments one thing
conversations are another thing so the
point is when you are providing
information through voice you need
sometimes you give more detail so for
example if you are saying to show some
example and giving some example from the
visual perspective this example can be a
suggestion chip on the response but this
will be audible for
user that does not have a that doesn't
have a screen available so we need to
give the example in the speech part so
this is importance when you have to
separate the speech between the text and
why you should separate them definitely
and it was actually really simple to
localize because literally it's the same
code except I've changed I've added this
I 18 dot n under stubble underscore and
that's the only thing once I pulled it
out so making your action localize when
I come to the Copart super easy the
translation it's a little different but
different so hopefully you have really
good Freddy's that speak multiple
languages to help you out on that and we
have another we have Sphero which is a
fantastic iot option yeah exactly
what one of our jobs as developer
advocate that I tend to say that's the
most fun job in the world we have to
play with some toys some things to study
right-to-work this is the good part of
being a developer advocate and one
challenge is how you can imagine okay we
are building actions that gonna run on
devices but if you have any startup or
have an idea and you are building a
hardware or any other appliance and you
like to make it work with the Google
system how it can works we have for
example the home automation framework
with home graph but if it's not for home
automation if I have like this robot I
won't you control these over voice and
this idea came when my daughter saw this
toy in the store in a shopping and I
said yeah looks like a nice toy but I
had to find the adult excuse to buy that
right so I said yeah maybe it's a good
so we can try with Google system and I
realized it when she was trying to
control the DS furo and she start
yelling at this fear stop stop that's it
cool I think these are you can throw
these over voice then using a a
smartphone or using a joystick
okay just it could be cool but okay is
another thing so what I decide to do is
to showcase how it could integrate any
kind of harder so for in this case
specifically this little ball it's using
bli blue
flow energy so what I have here it's
Raspberry Pi and I use every spare part
for the reason that I want to have
something on my desk that I can try the
ploy but you can for example build an
Android app that connects through the
Bluetooth and running your phone if you
want right so here we have a code that
that using the sphere onload ejs library
is sending commands to control this hero
and you know nothing new right I'm just
using the pre-existing API to send
commands over bluetooth and make the
ball run right but if I say ok G talk to
Roble and hey go forward go backward
turnleft turnright so then we decide to
do this I was planning to show it live
but the amount of Wi-Fi networks here is
interviewing of the the Wi-Fi signal and
to avoid other surprises I'm gonna show
you one of the video this for not we
were testing this and okay just play as
a volatile - Roble
move short forward move medium backward
move left short medium so all these
comments are going through dialog flow I
created some entities to identify the
movement like forward medium forward
backward left and right and I added this
speed component like is low or fast to
indicate how amount of time should move
in this case so of course this is is a
toy project the code will be soon
releasing on our github with a blog post
that's coming together but you can
imagine these as although you are
building appliance you are building
something cool and you like to control
these using the voice and with their
system right yeah that's super cool so I
know we only have like 10 seconds left
so I just want to do a shout out if you
do build an action and you go into
review it gets deployed on production
level um you do get automatically enter
to earn to our actions of your community
which means you get a cool shirt and
then let me read this because I would
say wrong $200 of cloud credits per
month for a year which is great to run
your actual bedroom money could be used
to translate your action using the
translate API as well and then this is
usually the photo that I recommend
everyone to take if you're interested in
building fractions on Google this
contains all the cool links and
resources to start off so we highly
recommend to actually start off using
our code lots and so it's on the right
hand it's a second one Cove ops go there
try our code lapse that we can get your
hands dirty and build an action for
yourself and if you are going to Google
i/o please visit us there we'll be there
all the days I have new code labs coming
for the Google i/o
either yes we will be there so and we
will be here on the at somewhere I think
the off showers move for some time we
have some pins and nice tracks so please
if you have any question we are happy to
answer yes thank you so much appreciate
it thank you
[Music]